bonsoir le 7-8 l'aktu sur tv fil 78 le
tour de l'actualité locale voici tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi 14 janvier
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui vote son budget
déficitaire pour 2014
le précédent conseil d'administration
avait été interrompue fin décembre par
des étudiants des enseignants et
dénonçant l'état des finances de
l'établissement le vote s'est déroulé
aujourd'hui dans le calme un prieuré
datant du xiième siècle se cache entre
poigny la forêt dr murray la mairie est
une association tente de le sauver
seulement le propriétaire c'est
surprenant ne semble pas très favorable
et puis spécial olympix première
organisation sportive au monde dédié aux
personnes déficientes intellectuelles
organise tout au long de l'année des
manifestations de l'une d'entre elle
voit on vient d'avoir lieu dans les
yvelines nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure à l'image du jour en attendant
cet après midi les élèves de terminale
de science et de technologie sanitaires
et sociales du lycée sonia-delaunay à
villepreux ont manifesté devant le
rectorat de versailles suite à l'annoncé
de la suppression des classes
préparatoires aux concours d'infirmier à
des classes présentes notamment dans
l'établissement et binoy depuis douze
ans de son côté le rectorat assure que
cette suppression de classe sera
réallouer au sein de l'académie de
versailles et propose donc d'offrir la
préparation à tous les élèves de
terminale de science et technologie
sanitaire et sociale en leur faisant
gagner ainsi une année d'étude quoi
qu'il arrive les élèves qui sont déjà
inscrits dans le cursus pourront aller
au bout pour préparer leur concours on
ne veut pas que ça soit supprimée dans
le sens où ça aide beaucoup les élèves
ça aide pas moins qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de payer des écoles privées pour
la préparer leurs enfants au concours
d'infirmier et comme jeudi concours
d'infirmier c'est vraiment voilà un
concours qu'ils sont obligés de le faire
mais bon ces élèves là qu'ils le font
c'est vraiment pour faire un métier qui
sont vite là une nouvelle réunion est
prévue à l'inspection académique à
guyancourt ce jeudi à 17 heures l'invité
du jour sébastien ramage bonsoir à vous
êtes président de l'unef à versailles
saint quentin en
evelyne à l'université on va revenir
avec vous sur cette situation et surtout
le vote du budget ce matin le budget
présenté en déséquilibre déficitaire il
n'a pas été validé par le rectorat un
autre budget elle doit donc être
présenté d'ici le 1er mars l'université
peut bien sûr continuer à fonctionner
catherine zola tôt pour plus de
précision avant que nous en discutions
en plateau c'est au sein des services
centraux rue de paris à versailles que
s'est tenu le conseil d'administration
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin un budget certes voté 16 voix
pour 8 voix contre
mais en déficit de 7 millions d'euros
qui n'a pas été validé par le recteur un
budget donc non conformes au code de
l'éducation et l'université a jusqu'au
1er mars pour présenter un nouveau
budget jérôme do vieux ne fait pas
partie du conseil d'administration mais
il était invité à y siéger au titre de
l'intersyndicale il faudra un aide
supplémentaire de l'état
moi je m'attendais à ce qu'elle soit
donnée déjà parce qu'il ya je pense que
les arbitrages globalement son fait la
ministre s'est exprimé sur ce point mais
on nous fait effectivement lanterner je
crois qu'au fond on nous demande de
faire encore plus d'économies c'est un
moyen de pression est là on voit le
marché de dupes de l'autonomie
financière des universités nous sommes
autonomes pour continuer à pressurer
universités pour que la ministre le
ministère nous donne si nous sommes
suffisamment sa gelée millions qui vont
nous manquer pour fonctionner c'est
comme ça que ça va changer d'emploi des
indes rapport des forces entre et herman
point de vue entre l'université de
ministère une donne simple soit le
ministère des blocs 7 millions d'euros
et le budget sera équilibré soit le
ministère ne donne pas 7 millions
d'euros et il faudra trouver des
économies supplémentaires
là on est dans une optique ou leur a
peut-être un peu des deux et même plus
d'économique de dotation et donc cela ne
nous satisfait pas c'est à nous aussi
d'interpeller le ministère c'est aux
syndicats pour étudiants et aux
syndicats professionnels de se mobiliser
et je pense que ça va être
notre perspective pour ce prochain mois
faut savoir que l'état dépense environ
1,5 milliard d'impôt recherche
son efficacité a remis en cause
actuellement et du coup ben on a cette
peace fait qu'il faut étudier je trouve
une certaine légèreté je dirais comme ça
la part de la ministre à continuer à
faire peser 10 ou une incertitude pour
obtenir encore plus d'économies rien
n'est vraiment réglé loin de là la seule
assurance obtenu par le président jean
luc bussière c'est que l'université peut
continuer de fonctionner normalement un
budget provisoire a été ouvert en
attendant donc la tenue d'un nouveau
conseil d'administration d'ici un mois
avec l'invité du journal nous allons
continuer à évoquer ce dossier de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
tout d'abord votre réaction au
l'entendue le budget a été voté il reste
déficitaire votre avis votre réaction
aujourd'hui alors nous ça faisait partie
d'une revendication c'est à dire que
l'université dans la mesure où on n'a
pas la capacité d'aujourd'hui de
fonctionner correctement sans avoir à
voter un budget en déficit ont demandé
au président effectivement de voter ce
budget illégales comme l'a dit jérôme
dans l'interview de sa pause rapport de
force vis-à-vis du ministère et donc
c'est déjà une première avancée mais
juste faut nuancer ce déficit parce que
enfin ce budget déficitaire il est
aujourd'hui déficitaire de 5,2 millions
d'euros sur un déficit total de 7
millions d'euros ça veut dire que tout
de même l'université consent à une
réduction à des restrictions budgétaires
de 2 millions d'euros ce qui correspond
à 17 postes que les -10% de
fonctionnement sur les composantes et
ses excès paierait donc ça pèse très
lourd tout même sur les conditions
d'études des étudiants
mais justement on va évoquer ce dossier
ce point précis du dossier le président
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin qui était à votre place la
semaine dernière qui nous expliquait que
et d'ici 2016 de budget ce serait
équilibré pour versailles et 50 ans vous
y croyez alors pas du tout tout
simplement parce que premièrement les
dotations du ministère en fin de compte
elles sont attribuées en fonction du
taux de réussite des étudiants
et si demain on consent à de nouvelles
restrictions budgétaires des nouvelles
suppressions d'heures de cours et bien
tout simplement ce même taux de réussite
il va chuter dans tous les cas on
n'arrivera pas être à l'équilibré en
2017 mais surtout 5 millions d'euros
d'économies ça correspond à la
suppression totale de toutes les heures
complémentaires qui à l'université ça se
précise ça correspond au gel de postes
jusqu'en 2017 et donc on se rend bien
compte que ce n'est pas une situation de
tôle qui est tenable
surtout dans la mesure où aujourd'hui le
ministère il n'annonce pas des nouvelles
dotations pour lui est ce qu est donc si
le ministère ne consent pas un
investissement supplémentaire dans l'ue
vs qu l'université pourra tout
simplement pas s'en sortir
est-ce que vous souhaitez aujourd'hui
avec ce budget déficitaire qui a été
votée c'est de mettre la pression sur
gouvernement sur le ministère de dire
aujourd'hui il faut une dotation plus
élevé dans ce sens là que vous avez vous
mobiliser dans les prochaines semaines
prochaines oui clairement
là déjà nous ce qu'on de ce qu'on
voulait depuis le début du mouvement
c'est que l'université soit un autre
côté dans ses revendications la bon ll a
donné un bon geste en votant un budget
déficitaire mais il reste encore
beaucoup à faire
et en ce qui concerne le ministère il
est évident que la situation du
financement du vs cuit et plus largement
de l'enseignement supérieur en france
elle est plutôt nabeul parce qu'on fait
des choix
l'argent il y en a un pour investir dans
l'enseignement supérieur mais on fait
des choix qui sont pas forcément au
service de la formation et de la
réussite des étudiants mais des choix
qui sont élitistes soit investi avec le
crédit impôt recherche
thibault en parlais tout à l'heure 5
milliards d'euros par an tu m'aimes ce
crédit d'impôt recherche ou investit
dans des entreprises sans contrepartie
20 milliards d'euros pour le sehy ce
camp nou à l'unef on demande simplement
pour les quelques années à venir
370 millions d'euros ce qui n'est pas
énorme pour au moins sortir les sites
université de la situation dans laquelle
sont aujourd'hui 370 millions à comparer
aux milliards investis dans le crédit
impôt recherche ou encore dans les
investissements d'avenir
juste une précision vous avez bien
précisé que vous apparteniez à l'unef
rappelle que vous en êtes le président à
versailles 50 ans on avait aussi évoqué
sur ce plateau avec d'autres
représentons une union avec l'unique et
l'organisation syndicale plutôt de
droite à l'université est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'union sacrée
justement autour de cette défense de
l'université alors je pense que l'uni et
l'unef on n'est pas forcément dans la
même démarche et on n'a pas forcément
les mêmes opinions politiques
premièrement nous notre objectif c'est
pas juste de taper sur le gouvernement
et dire vous êtes méchant hollande fait
une politique qui nous mène dans le mur
c'est pas nous on n'est pas là pour des
raisons politiques de dire qu'il n'est
pas partir unie pour aller demander des
fonds supplémentaires
de toute façon nous
les assemblées générales avec
l'intersyndicale on a une organisation
syndicale et donc pourra se joindre à
nous tout étudiants qui le souhaitent
donc si les adhérents de l'uni souhaite
se joindre à nous pour se mobiliser ils
peuvent le faire mais j'ai voulu mener
le bal en tout cas c'est une
mobilisation qui est syndicale pour
commencer on va faire une assemblée
générale et tous les étudiants pourront
participer auront une voix pour
reprendre la parole etc etc
donc c'est bien un mouvement qui a
vocation à s'étendre à tout le monde
bon après en ce qui concerne les
revendications l'unef
elle se sert de cette mobilisation aussi
pour se battre contre la sélection à
l'université pour se battre contre les
restrictions budgétaires qui sont faites
sur les formations et là nos points de
vue divergent clairement avec les autres
associations d'université alors où est
il possible de faire des économies dans
le budget parce qu'il va falloir faire
des économies il malgré tout même si le
ministère fini par céder par vous donner
de l'argent ça ne sera pas forcément
suffisant alors je pense qu'il ya des
économies déjà à faire au niveau des
partenariats public privé on en avait
déjà parlé sur ce plateau
ça veut dire aux négociateurs ont réussi
à négocier effectivement une partie d'un
des ppp donc le contrat le partenariat
public privé avec cofely
on a réussi à negro négocier donc à
reprendre la main sur la maintenance et
sur l'entretien de l'université ce qui
fait économiser 500 mille euros par an
mais il faut aller plus loin
c'est à dire que c'est un contrat qui
nous engage sur 25 ans qui coûte
aujourd'hui 1,2 million d'euros à
l'université chaque année et c'est un
contrat que l'université a pas les
moyens de financer
mais encore une fois on en revient
encore une fois au ministère on pourra
pas sortir de ce contrat si l'ue
ministère nous fournira un soutien
juridique est aussi financier pour s'en
sortir
et du côté des formations on supprime
certaines formations qui ne font pas le
plan du côté des étudiants du côté des
inscriptions parce que c'est le cas au
niveau des masters il va y avoir moins
d'accompagnement aussi à certains
masters qui attire pas beaucoup d'élèves
qui vont disparaître
alors voilà c'est une proposition de la
part de l'université supprimer des
masters qui n'ont pas de sens
il ya trois étudiants dans la classe 4 e
étudiant 5 étudiants ça fait d'accord
pourquoi pas oui même si on préférait
faire des économies ailleurs
mais dans tous les cas cette marge de
manoeuvre sur les d'économies sur
quelques masters elle est très faible en
fin de sa représente quelques dizaines
de milliers d'euros
le gros du déficit le gros du déficit
structurel de l'université il vient de
son manque de dotation et donc
en tous les cas l'université sera obligé
de voir sa dotation augmenté sinon elle
pourra pas s'en sortir
et justement l'université qui ne peut
pas s'en sortir fin décembre c'est le
président à l'université qu'il disait
une possible une possibilité de voir
l'université fermée
c'est envisageable ou là aussi c'était
une ration supplémentaire son ministère
voilà c'était une pression sur sur le
ministère nous on a on a été extrêmement
choqué par cette proposition de
l'universite simplement parce que elle
avait deux objectifs mettre la pression
du mystère mais aussi mobilisé étudiants
parce que en leur faisant peur et en
disant voilà voilà ce qui vous risquez
vous arriver ils ont eu peur justement
les étudiants ils ont eu peur en effet
mais c'est pas là dessus que nous on
souhaite mobiliser sur 11,7 pas les
prendre en otage et leur dire soit vous
mobiliser soit en faire votre fac de
toute façon le ministère l'a rappelé
aussi par un communiqué de presse
80 % la dotation de l'ue est ce qu elle
est dotée c'est un service public donc
il a une principe de continuité il n'a
pas vocation à fermer et n'a pas même
pas légal que l'université ferme et donc
il ya aucune crainte à avoir à ce niveau
là en revanche sur les restrictions
budgétaires
si l'université trouve pas de dotation
et je le répète encore là il va y aura
de lourdes conséquences en terme de
pédagogie d'accompagnement des étudiants
et au final en terme de réussite à
l'université donc vous serez est
mobilisée à travers notamment une
intersyndicale vous nous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure durant les prochaines semaines
prochains mois merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau président de l'unef je rappelle
donc que le budget de l'université de
versailles saint quentin a été voté ce
matin un budget est déficitaire retour à
l'équilibré en tout cas envisagé en 2016
pour la présidence des salariés en
colère ceux du site fujifilm medical
systems de montigny le bretonneux
l'établissement emploie une soixantaine
de salariés et un projet de
réorganisation est en cours avec un
autre établissement basé à asnières qui
lui emploie 190 personnes
dans ce projet il est prévu 30 et une
mutation de postes de montigny à
asnières et est globalement 53
suppressions
les salariés du site yvelinois reproche
le manque de dialogue avec la direction
ils ont entamé un début de grève
une grève qu'ils veulent ils imiter les
explications micro de claire cambier sur
montigny savez bien
mais sur asnières ça va pas bien mais
c'est quand même mon unique est quand
même le plus touché puisque c'est quand
même les salariés de montigny qui vont
perdre le le plus gros quoi parce que
les gens sont là depuis très longtemps
on était quand même une entreprise très
familial malgré tout et on va perdre ça
et c'est c'est écoeurant quoi on ne sait
pas encore en fait dans quelles
conditions les gens vont aller sur
asnières et dans quelles conditions les
gens vont partir pour ceux qui ne
pourront pas suivre
fujifilm medical systems france ne va
pas bien du tout hors l'endoscopie va
très bien si l'endoscopie en fait qui va
en pâtir le plus les premiers départs du
site de montigny vers celui d'asnières
pourrait se dérouler dès le mois de
septembre 2014 les salariés de montigné
qui était aujourd'hui mobilisée à
asnières pour discuter avec la direction
la mobilisation revient demain dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin les
salariés seront de retour pour occuper
le terrain avec leurs collègues cette
fois ci des hauts de seine
ce mardi soir robert cadalbert président
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines devrait tenir sa dernière
cérémonie de voeux au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sauf surprise
il devrait annoncer un retrait de la vie
politique locale il se dit en effet
depuis plusieurs semaines que celui qui
siège aussi en tant que conseiller
municipal ps à guyancourt ne serait pas
sur la nouvelle liste conduite par le
maire sortant françois de ligné en mars
prochain
il ne pourra donc pas prétendre à un
nouveau mandat de président de la
communauté d'agglomération pour être élu
il faut en effet siéger dans l'une des
villes membres l'une des sept villes de
l'agglomération alors pourquoi un tel
départ alors qu'il avait été annoncé il
y a quelques mois deux s'étaient
d'ailleurs sur cette antenne son
intention d'être candidat à guyancourt
nous lui poserons la question a dans
notre édition du 7 8 l'aktu de demain
mercredi dès 18 heures robert cadalbert
sera l'invité de la rédaction
entre sujet justice pendant trente ans
il a exercé le métier d'architecte alors
qu'il n'en avait pas le diplôme et la
construit à notamment plusieurs écoles
dans le département et même une
polyclinique
le procès de cet homme aujourd'hui âgé
de 59 ans s'est ouvert hier à versailles
il a déjà été renvoyé au 23 juin dans
l'attenté d'une décision de la cour
d'appel
lionel torrès pendant trente ans il
s'est fait passer pour un architecte
sans en avoir le diplôme
philippe leblanc 59 ans a comparu ce
lundi devant le tribunal correctionnel
de versailles jugé pour escroquerie et
leur passion de diplômes son procès a
été renvoyé au 23 juin prochain
d'après son avocat philippe leblanc
serait très affecté par ce procès il est
fatigué et épuisé par cette procédure
parce que nerveusement pas difficile à
tenir
donc pas encore une fois tout le
préjudice matériel avéré un mais moi en
tout cas je n'ai pas la preuve formelle
il ya eu des constructions qui a été mal
réalisée la preuve en est c'est qu'il ya
eu aucune expertise judiciaire
danser dans cette affaire qu'ils aient
pu constater mais quelques malfaçons ce
soit une version contestée du côté des
parties civiles l'avocat des assureurs
évoque des constructions non terminés
défaillante et non garantis car si le
suspect n'avait pas le diplôme il a tout
de même réussi à construire de nombreux
bâtiments publics dans les yvelines
à son actif notamment des écoles un
collège animer des crèches ou encore
cette polyclinique à mantes la jolie
mais selon l'avocat des assureurs c'est
d'abord la tromperie qui doit être jugé
c'est pas forcément un dossier civil de
malfaçons n'est pas là pour le juger sur
laquelle travaille pour juger pour avoir
trompé non des cocontractants et des
assureurs sur ce qu'il fait réellement
voilà il est assuré pour une mission ils
ont fait une autre il a trompé tout le
monde en réponse à tout philippe leblanc
est jugé sur la période 2009-2013
période pendant laquelle il aurait
facturé 926 1000 euros d'honoraires
l'imposture avaient été révélés au
printemps dernier par ce médecin évinois
à la suite d'un différend avec le
prétendu architectes en mêlant sa petite
enquête sur internet il avait découvert
que le prévenu était inconnu à l'ordre
et avait porté plainte
en attendant son procès et philippe
leblanc reste sous contrôle judiciaire
et n'a pas le droit d'exercer
il aurait même repris ses études et
devrait obtenir son diplôme d'ici cet
été
sport le programme jeunes athlètes
permet d'utiliser les valeurs véhiculées
par le sport justement pour aider au
développement des enfants en situation
de handicap de 2 à 8 ans développé
depuis 2007 à travers le monde une étape
vient de se dérouler aujourd'hui mardi à
carrières-sur-seine olivier maniscalco
patrick jacques de dixmude étaient
présents un programme de sport adapté
pour des tout petits handicapés ce mardi
l'association spécial olympics présenter
l'initiative jeune athlète à l'institut
médico éducatif de carrières-sur-seine
destinée aux enfants de 2 à 8 handicapés
mentaux le programme mis en place dès
2007 vise à améliorer grâce aux valeurs
du sport les conditions de vie de ces
tout petits
on est encore dans les prémices de
l'organisation là c'est une première une
démonstration les enfants donc ont été
sollicités les familles ont été
sollicités l'objectif c'est de les
réunir avoir du personnel qui est mis à
contribution et d'organiser une séance
d'activité sur la base d'activités
motrices avec des parcours des choses à
escalader et des choses qui sont
totalement adapté à leur niveau à leur
âge développer la motricité dépasser les
craintes confrontés les enfants à
différents milieux et leur faire gagner
en confiance
beaucoup d'objectifs sont visés à
travers ces ateliers accompagnés
d'éducateurs spécialisés
autre objectif primordial pour
l'association mixez enfants valides et
non valides et dès le plus jeune âge
afin de les faire grandir ensemble plus
tolérants face à la différence que
représente le handicap
je pense que c'est important pour nos
enfants handicapés mais c'est très
important pour les enfants valides
pour pour plus tard pour leur éducation
pour leur acceptation de l'autre leur
compréhension et je trouve que c'est
aujourd'hui en france on a on est dans
une dans un pays où le handicap est pas
forcément très bien accepté et je trouve
que ces projets pour les petits valident
leur permettront plus tard de mieux
accepter la différence prendre en charge
les enfants pour faire souffler des
parents fatigués fait aussi partie du
programme jeunes athlètes
un programme qui avait déjà bénéficié à
près de 95 mille enfants à travers le
monde
en 2011 l'objectif est d'en faire
profiter cent mille d'ici 2015
patrimoine les bois de poids ni et la
forêt qui cache un véritable trésor du
12e siècle qui risque de s'effondrer à
tout moment la mairie est une
association sauvons les moulineaux se
mobilisent
anthony rech à quelques kilomètres de
poids ni la forêt derrière la végétation
se cachent les ruines d'une ancienne
abbaye est le plus surprenant se trouve
à l'intérieur
dans le coeur des moulineaux la voûte
est quasiment resté intact comme si elle
voulait résisté au temps mais pour toute
rénovation l'accord du propriétaire qui
n'a pas répondu à nos sollicitations est
indispensable pourtant l'association et
là mairie de poigny la forêt ont tenté à
plusieurs reprises de trouver un terrain
d'entente
on lui a fait des propositions on lui a
fait une proposition de deux délégations
de 8,6 ouvrage finances forme de bail
emphytéotique ce qui n'a pas donné suite
on lui a fait une proposition de rachat
de son delà de la parcelle
donc de trois hectares qui englobe le
prieuré il n'a pas donné suite
pour l'instant il fait le mort mais à
tout moment la porte reste ouverte
c'est-à-dire que nous notre souhait le
plus profond c'est de faire du
propriétaire en allier les moulineaux
sont un des rares témoignages de l'ordre
religieux de grand monde qui aurait
occupé le site au 12e siècle et surtout
une bibliothèque à ciel ouvert dont
beaucoup d'histoires sont encore à
découvrir
l'association a donc écrit au ministère
de la culture et au préfet de région
afin de faire protéger le site grâce au
label monuments historiques
suite aux sollicitations la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles doit
prochainement formuler un avis préalable
à la déclaration de statut de protection
d'urgence
ça nous donne un an c'est pas grand
chose mais pendant cette année la
procédure de classement elle continuera
à avancer et on espère que cette
procédure de placement
vu la protection d'urgence qui aura été
émise sur le site pourra donner lieu à
une signature du préfet de région
une pétition vient d'être lancée sur
internet une nouvelle réunion est prévue
le 27 janvier avec le sous-préfet le
ministère de la culture est le
propriétaire
le cheval meilleur compagnon de l'homme
mais aussi partenaires thérapeutique
idéal l'équithérapie complémentaire aux
soins médicaux se développe bien que ce
soit une pratique peu conventionnel
comment se déroule une séance le
reportage de yolaine thorez avant de
prendre la direction du manège l'heure
est à la préparation des chevaux depuis
plus de deux ans et adolescents monte à
cheval
ici chaque semaine ils font partie de
l'institut médico-éducatif le castella
gaz rend celui-ci accueille une
cinquantaine de personnes handicapées
dont ces trois jeunes autistes
pour eux cette sortie n'est pas une
simple séance d'équitation
on parle d'équithérapie on recherche
vraiment
par l'équithérapie le contact avec le
cheval et qu' ils se sentent plus à
l'aise et qu'ils arrivent un peu évolué
en autonomie ouais je prends le cerceau
stéphane leurs éducateurs a pu voir
l'évolution de chacun d'entre eux au
départ yanis avait besoin de deux
personnes à ses côtés pour rester en
équilibre
aujourd'hui il se tient seul sur le
cheval cette séance c'est aussi pour ces
jeunes autistes une véritable bouffée
d'oxygène
c'est des jeunes normalement qui ont des
difficultés de comportement qui ont des
comportements inadaptés et qu'on a
toujours un petit peu tendance à la pas
trop sortir avant tout c'est une
activité qui leur fait plaisir parce
quand c'est des jeunes qui ont besoin de
stimulation
ces adolescents serait très sensible aux
chevaux et nour et même une relation
fusionnelle avec eux le moniteur est
d'ailleurs très surpris
luna un de ses chevaux est beaucoup plus
calme en leur compagnie
on donne à hadji les yeux fermés alors
que c'est une jument qui as est
caractériel
en règle générale et ça on voit vraiment
le changement de comportement d'une
personne à l'autre et encore plus avec
avec avec des autistes comme et pour
plus de reportages santé je vous
rappelle le magazine check up de la
rédaction tous les horaires de diffusion
sur notre site internet ainsi que les
replays des anciennes émissions fin du
journal pour ce 14 janvier rendez vous
demain 18h en direct avec catherine
mulato votre soirée sur téléphiles c'est
un nouveau numéro de municipales 2014
émission politique et 2 tv fils
excellente soirée